i asked jimmy um and maya whenever they
were here
uh memories of prince you know because i
heard about the huge 40th anniversary
snow party
and it sounds like the most epic party
in all of the lands
so what do you remember about that night
well i mean it was the party that only
exists
in like works of fiction you never would
have that many people
together again but i remember my wife
and i were weaving through the crowd
right as prince was on stage
and it's very strange you never think of
like famous people going like this
excuse me
excuse me um but it was so densely
packed
and uh i was doing the excuse me and
then just came like you know my face
came like this close
uh to beyonce and i we were you know we
our eyes met
and i just was like pretty cool party
right and she said
yeah and then we just kept going like
the momentum took us away
and uh my wife said wow you really
really killed that interaction
and then you better you better leave
your ringer on because you're probably
gonna get a call from beyonce
she said hi and then i said hi and then
it was over yeah i
don't know if you heard i was like
pretty cool party right and then she was
like yeah i'm like
we went pretty good yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever